But this is not what I want to do. This is not my current forte.
I think that I have other stuff that I >> No, this is your
only forte. This is the only thing he's good at. >> He
is useless as a political actor at this point. Also, you want
a ceasefire, bro? Hey, ceasefire. Little ceasefire, bro. We got
a little ceasefire in here. Little ceasefire dog. Little little
cease. Hey, I'm I'm calling off the dogs, bro. All right. We
could stop this. We can stop this now. Is it Is it an Ompic shirt?
Would would there be some reason we'd put Nicholas Yorio's Queen
and Wigler in an Osmpic shirt? That's still very He's lost nothing
in terms of being like a totally vicious internet bully. Okay,
I'm just telling you like everything's still there. A ton of
the community is still there. They're going to go after somebody.
They will figure out a bunch of stuff about you and they'll go
after you. Right.
That's it for I think that's just about it for my uh my coverage
of this. Okay, we're moving forward. We're moving forward. We're
moving on. We're moving upwards onwards to better. Uh I keep
getting updates on Nicholas's stream, but I think we're going
to go to the Destiny stream first and then, you know, we'll we'll
cover some of Nicholas's stuff after. Okay. I'm getting word
that it's it's quite a good stream. All right,
so give me a second here. Oh, real quick as a quick pallet cleanser.
Not pallet cleanser, leading into the next segment. Okay, >> the
profile is on thing. the profile was deleted after no activity
since 2013. All post and comments and then he actually openly
admitted it too.
Um he he admitted it I believe. So
um your ops are having a off. It is pretty crazy what's going
on over there. But I think you guys understand
um I think you guys understand why I just like actively avoid
that side of the universe if you know what I'm saying, right?
Like like you kind of get a better handle on that sort of thing.
I
I wonder what Asmin Gold is doing because he's been like a he's
been like a third party beacon on this conflict mostly used against
me. Does he cover this at all? I feel like this would be right
in his wheelhouse, but I suspect it's like both communities that
he is actively farming from.
So I I suspect he's just ignoring it and and not talking about
it at all. Now imagine if that is something Imagine if I had
ever done something so insane. Of course it would be of course
that would be the the number one uh worldending uh drama story.
You know >> Victory Lab Hassan Victory Lab plus you know
little shot at Asmin Gold on the way out. I do find it weird.
Has really not or sorry has Asmin Gold really not covered any
of this?
That does seem weird doesn't it
hasn't looked at it at all? Like isn't that Willy Mack video
in Isn't that like insane?
Like what what would be the goal in not covering that? I actually
don't know. Like what would what would why why would you not
cover it? Oh, real quick. Apparently um apparently Nicholas got
made a a wigler made for him. But um >> that so so if you
guys didn't see when we did that clip earlier when Nicholas does
a Queenman impression, Nicholas got his his Queen and Wiggler
from somebody who added some little changes to it. Okay. I' I've
been getting told about these changes and apparently Queen just
revealed it. So I don't want to I don't want to step on his toes
on this one. Okay, this is one of his community members who did
it.
>> Original, I think. >> Do we notice any can we
spot the difference between my wigler and this >> So, there's
a there's a face here. I see. Oh, there's a little face on the
cup. Okay. There's a little face on the cup. In Queman's on Queen's
cup, there's no face. There's no skull.
That's cool. There's a little Hold on. There's a little Palestinian
flag. Is that a Is that a Palestinian flag in the drink? Oh my
god. With the little umbrellas. That's a little Palestinian flag
right there, isn't it? And hold on. You notice Queen's shirt
is just gray. Okay, it's just gray. There's nothing on it. It's
a little little update for Dioro's shirt. Okay, now I don't know.
Nicholas put this wiggler on stream, by the way. Okay, Nicholas,
put this wiggler on stream. Seems like the the Nicholas wiggler
uh there's Zi
or EMP. Oh, is it is it an OMIC shirt? Would would there be some
reason we'd put Nicholas Yorio's Queen and Wigler in an OMIC
shirt?
boy. Oh boy. Oh boy. >> So there there's a there's an Osmpic
logo
on the >> So I'll just I'll play it again in case you guys
didn't catch it [__] freshman in school. People watch
this [__] and they're like you sabotage Ethan [__]
How? So, I think this is where the Destiny thing starts with
the Ethan stuff. We've got that. I've got a clip that goes with
this and then I don't know where we're going to go after this.
Uh, I have not watched any of this yet. So, we're really we're
coming into this as our first reaction to it. Okay, we'll see
what exactly Destiny had to say today. I'm not totally sure.
Oh, hold on. Destiny versus H3 ending
Dude, I don't know if you're Ethan. If you're Ethan, do you let
it go? Destiny is the guy. I posted this earlier today. Okay.
Destiny is the guy who showed everyone that your dad jerks off
to your wife's pictures. You just going to let that go? You really
just going to let that go?
He showed everybody on Twitter that your dad jerks off to your
girlfriend? Your wife? Sorry. Your wife. Your wife. Your wife.
Your wife. Obviously your wife. Isn't that weird that your dad
would make an account on
and fa his only pinned picture is of your wife without pants
on? Isn't that if you're Ethan, do you let this go or is this
like this is like a blood debt now? That seems kind of rough,
dude.
Anyway, let's see what see what Destiny has to say here. Okay,
now I talked about this with some people off stream a little
bit. Okay, just the idea that like one I cannot believe
I cannot
that Ethan came at Destiny over like like a lot of it was jokes,
right? Like like there are real problems with what Destiny's
done. That's why Destiny skipped the entire thing over over Rose
the child stuff. He skipped all of that, right? But for the rest,
like there are some jokes in there that Ethan was like, "Oh,
I'm going to totally soy out
And I don't understand how he did that given his past like satirical
approach to this. I don't understand how he thought that was
a good angle of attack for him, right? Isn't that crazy to go
and do that? And it's funny that you'd pick a fight with Destiny
when I think Destiny's lost any chance at legitimacy as a political
figure, right?
>> But this guy is absolutely never forget that this guy
is still very capable as just an internet bully.
>> Gary probably sees her as a viral target. Okay, thank
you very much. Ruben Ruben Dass is still very he's lost nothing
in terms of being like a totally vicious internet bully. Okay,
I'm just telling you like everything's still there. A ton of
the community is still there. They're going to go after somebody.
They will figure out a bunch of stuff about you and they'll go
after you, right? He's been staying up late while he had to research
this whole Ethan piece on his own. Okay, cuz the the DG crew
that he's got left, they don't do a great job. All right, but
Ethan went at this guy when this guy's got nothing left to lose.
Basically, that's probably the worst time you could go at Destiny
like this, right? Is when he's got nothing left to lose. Like,
he really has nothing he's trying to like save himself or or
like any credibility for now. He can say anything he wants.
I'm not sure most were jokes. So, some of them were jokes. Some
of them were obvious jokes. Okay. A lot of them weren't jokes.
The 15-year-old thing, that wasn't a joke. That wasn't him telling
the boys to just like, "Hey, stay on the lookout. Stay vigilant,
guys. There's some underage girls around here, and don't get
caught. Don't Don't try to have sex with them. Don't do that.
That's definitely not what he was doing there. But I'm saying
some of them were jokes and Ethan makes a lot of he has made
a lot of jokes like that. Destiny really leaning into the Well,
don't don't spoil yet substance. Okay, we're going to check it
out. Apparently, yes, this could be Destiny on this. >> I
won't make the jokes. Never mind. Okay,
listen. All right. It's been a uh fortuitous. Is that a word
I could use here? Happening by accident or transfer than design.
I could use it, but that's not what I'm looking for. Okay, the
last week been a lot of stuff going on. Okay, we've been fighting
in the trenches.
There's been a a lot of lot of stuff that has been uh
happening and everything else. Okay,
I would like to reiterate
I don't think
I'm pretty sure
nobody involved here is an actual child or anything like that.
Okay. I feel like my
um Okay. Like
I understand a lot of people don't see a huge difference between
somebody who retains child and a Okay. So, let's let's just say
between the two of you, one of you has
clearly made it made it very clear that they have retained in
some way child. Okay. So, you could say, "Oh, nobody here is
a child is a Okay, nobody here is a child predator." But I mean,
come on, man. >> I point spoke shortly enough the way that
I intended them. I think enough people have understood what I'm
trying to say. Obviously, there was some uh more meme stuff uh
that was kind of dug up yesterday um that people are running
through. I'm going to reiterate something I said. I think I said
this at the beginning of my
thing. What did I write down? I don't
like doing this content. Okay, brother. This guy's out of his
mind right now. I don't guys I don't like doing this content
brother. You were doing this content on people who aren't even
content creators for funsies like a month ago. Are you talking
about as much as I used to? All right. It's a little bit fun
to adult every now and then. I'll be honest. Okay. But this is
not what I want to do. This is not my current forte. I think
that I have other stuff that I >> No, this is your only
forte. This is the only thing he's good at. He is useless as
a political actor at this point. >> Enjoy doing a lot more
now. Um, I don't particularly like doing the whole back and forth
nuke after nuke after nuke. Uh, it's just not, this is not the
kind of content I want to do. I've been sucked back into it,
okay,
cuz they killed my dog. All right, but yeah. Uh, I'm sure that
Ethan and the crew are probably getting a lot of attention, negative,
whatever.
Uh, my community is not supposed to brigade or harass. I think
I told all my mods, okay, we're done. Ethan posting. We're done.
H3 posting. Uh I'm not looking to pile on for the next like week
or two weeks. If you understand how like the waves of the internet
work, obviously
we I we had our stuff yesterday and there's probably going to
be um the ripples from I'm sure Hassan and others today if they
haven't already or people around him and then the commentary
people will pick it up and they'll do all that. Yeah. So I'm
I'm good where I'm at.
Hey Ethan, your dad's a total degenerate. He's commenting on
stars when they're posting pictures of themselves when they're
minors. He's like asking to this to put her schoolgirl outfit
on and then he uh jerks off to your wife, Ethan. Also, you want
a ceasefire, bro? Hey, ceasefire. Little ceasefire, bro. We got
a little ceasefire in here. Yeah, I know. I I know I pointed
out that your dad jerks off to your wife, but like little ceasefire,
dog. Little little cease. Hey, I'm I'm calling off the dogs,
bro. All right, we can stop this. we can stop this now. There's
no way because here's the thing. Ethan had the the is there for
Destiny here, right? Like he says, "Oh, this isn't my content.
This isn't what I want to do. This isn't where I'm going anymore."
Right? He says these things, but he is the thing that made this
new cycle appear. But for him leaking content of Rose that only
he had, if he had not done this, there wouldn't be the Rose is
a minor news cycle going on. right? That wouldn't exist.
There would never be the roses a minor thing that's happening
right now where where it's been proven out beyond a shadow of
a doubt in eight different ways. Now, by the way, there are so
many different ways this has been proven
that like it it's it's not that the pictures of the girl that
Destiny posted in his chat said this was Rose, gave away her
college, posted pictures of her face, okay, so Kiwi Farms could
dox them. That girl who got doxed was a minor when Desty got
from them and traded with them and he put that info out there
so she could be found.
Right? So he says, "Oh, I I've gotten sucked back in. You put
yourself in this. You invented this." Right? You You made this
all happen. You're the only one who's done it.
Ethan didn't do this to you. Hassan didn't do this to you. You
did this to you. So I'm wondering if Ethan can really let this
go. Right. when when Ethan is clearly in the right. Desi is clearly
in the wrong. Can Ethan actually let this go? I don't know. I
don't know, man. I don't care. I don't mind if people make like
measured criticisms of me if somebody wants to say I'm a or somebody
wants to say um I can be whatever, you know? I just I don't care.
But if you're gonna go hard into the paint and say I'm like
>> um child connoisseur, perpetual habitual consent violator
would be the two titles I would say are accurate. Um not even
like contentious,
right? Do I have to call him a do I think he's a primary attraction
to previewing kids? No. Um, lots of people will think is synonymous
with child connoisseur, but you know, it's it's not quite I'll
just I'll stick with the with my version. Okay. >> Some
creepy predator who has a history of doing all this, and you're
going to continue to lay on that point. Then I'm going to Well,
I'm going to obviously lay out my points as well. Then that's
what we're going to do. We could do that. I don't mind it. Uh,
I think I can still do it. I feel like we've shown that we can
still do it. Um, I just am not interested in that per se. But,
okay. So,
by the way, the funny thing about this is is he's not even remotely
pretending that he's defended himself, right? Like, I've proven
that I can still do this. I can call you stuff, too. And I think
the best thing would be it's like, dude, it's like basically
somebody calls you names and you punch them in the face, right?
Not even calls you names. Somebody says you like stole from them
and you did steal from them and you punched them in the face.
You go. Unless you want me to punch you in the face again. Admit
that you lied about steal me stealing from you. That's what's
happened to Ethan right now, right? Like Ethan Ethan's doing
a valid criticism of Destiny. Little little bit over the top.
Okay. A little too far, but a mostly valid criticism. And Destiny
just punched him in the face and was like, "Tell everybody that
you lied about me."
Like, but he's not saying he didn't do it. He's not ever saying,
"No, I didn't steal from you. No, I didn't retain that child."
He's not saying that. He's saying, "I just hit you in the mouth,
and unless you want another, you tell everybody that I didn't
do that." Okay. It's crazy. He's not even pretending to defend
himself.
Did you offer him a ceasefire? No, because I don't have any direct
communication with him at all. I don't communicate with it directly.
We have still not don't communicate directly. I just see him
Instagram stories at me and then I launch tweets at him. Um,
but yeah, I'm just saying like I'm done talking about it. My
communities are going to be done posting about it. Um, yeah,
that's it. Uh, this includes the Willie Mac stuff. Um, for the
rest of the commentary, I don't give a [__] about
them. Honestly, Willie Mack already docks this person. Ethan
goes live the next stream and just says, "You know what? Let's
go show the evidence that this girl is 17 and exactly how Destiny
found it all. Let's just walk through it and show exactly how
this person was found."
You could do it. It's pretty doxy. It's pretty crazy to get into.
I don't know if you'd want to do it on YouTube,
but he could do it, right? And that just that explodes everything
Destiny's saying. By the way, if you actually did that, that
explodes everything Destiny's saying. I don't know if you can
get around I don't know if you can do that with the current toos.
Okay, so we'll see. We'll see what Ethan decides to do. I think
you could get around the toos and still prove it out, though.
As we saw from last night, right, Tom Foolery was doing it last
night. Let me Let me pull this Tom Foolery clip up. Who Who sent
this to me? Is it Black Irish? I think so. Tom Tom pulled it
up. >> Picture of her. And so Tom was showing it. I just
kind of showed her mouth and showed that you can see there's
like a small birthark or >> Tom's got all this up on his
Tom's just going in. Okay, Tom's going all the way in right now.
If Tom can do it, why can't Ethan? That's all I'm saying. Okay,
if Tom can do it, why can't Ethan Klein? That birthday, that
birthday is something, isn't it? I don't care. If you guys want
to [__] on them, go for it. I don't care. Um, I just
the in my mind I think one of the most upsetting things about
everything that happened there's two really upsetting things.
One is that it gave two huge communities. This whole kind of
weird lefty apparatus and then all of the snarkers/ anti-fan/
kiwi farmers. this was like their gold mine of attention and
while I'm sure there are some H3 snarkers or leftovers people,
I'm sure there are a whole bunch of people who are uh probably
happier with me or enjoy me more than not right now because of
everything that happened. Uh I don't like those types of people.
I don't want to I
I Okay, I don't want to be the main character right now, but
I have a feeling Destiny was watching me um kind of like being
like I think he's misrepresenting things. I think he's misrepresenting
things. And at some point I flip and I go, "Dude, what is Ethan
doing?" Like trying to criticize him when he's got all this in
his past, right? And I just started laughing at Ethan. I have
a feeling somehow in my head I'm like, he saw that. I don't think
that's true. Okay, I think he's probably trying to be calculated
here. But in my head, in my head cannon, okay, he saw me laughing
at Ethan Klein and was like, "Oh no, what have I done? What have
I done?" Foster those types of people as an audience. Uh I don't
want my audience to hear those types of people. So I don't give
a [__] about those people, okay? [__]
them. I don't want that audience. I don't care about them. I
don't care if they like that I did this or whatever. Um, I also
don't well I don't I would imagine that Ethan probably doesn't
want to engender too much uh Kiwi farm support because it also
leads to a bunch of like weird horrible stupid um stuff happening.
So like like Destiny doxing you and your family like Ethan, you
wouldn't want to get too much Kiwi Farm support or else you would
become a valid DGG military target, Ethan. Okay. And you don't
want
>> Yeah. So that it sucks that like the weird lefty communities
and then the snarker communities all have um all have their stuff.
Um they all have their day in the sun which is annoying. Um oh
it's also annoying because I think that me and Ethan's content
is pretty different uh in terms of what H3 does. I think that
their audience I've said this before their audience is like heavily
uh women. I think it's actually 60/40 uh woman versus man versus
man versus woman. Um I thought it was 460. I think it's 6040.
And I think my style of content and everything else is um
it leans much more masculine or whatever debate, whatever the
[__] you want to call it. So I understand there's
not a necessarily an organic crossover there, but we I think
we were like the only two like left-leaning places on the internet
that was still not hardcore
anti-semitic burn all the that's just simply not true even remotely.
There's tons of left leading places on the internet that aren't
anti-Semitic. There's like all literally all of the Brian Tyler
Co and David Pacman like anti-Trump people, right? All the Midas
touch people.
What [__] is this even supposed to say? You guys
aren't even close to the biggest creators who do semi-political
content. Like, shut the [__] up. This is just totally
made up. >> Hell every single person, which every other
[__] left community has gone that direction of. So,
I think it's like a little bit sad if our communities are literally
trying to destroy each others. Um, which my community is not
going to be destroyed. So, yeah. Um, yeah. I just think that's
like really I just it's a it's a it's a bad fight. It's a I think
it's a stupid community fight to have. I think that there are
I think I've said this before even before today. Um, people are
What did I say before today? Oh, [__] I just my I
read something in chat. My mind hop something else. Oh, I think
I said before today, I know I did. I don't know why I said I
think I did. I know I said this before today, that I think Ethan
and I were two of the only people to make the jump from being
very edgy in the 2010s to being like pretty progressive and wokey
in the 2020s without being so >> Is he not uh is he not
edgy anymore? >> Like a lot of people failed that jump.
They either quit content creation or they are still edgy and
they turned into Local. So your um Keemst stars and your uh boogies
and all that or they they became woke but they also lost their
comedic edge right so like Ian is a really great example of that
who became
is that not exactly this was by the way before Ethan was like
fighting with this was Destiny's exact opinion of Ethan was that
he was woke he was a loser he wasn't funny right this was the
precise opinion he had of Ethan for like a ton of time he's actually
describing his previous character erization of Ethan >> supered
out and is no longer funny or entertaining to watch even though
he became ultra war progressive. So yeah, I just think I just
feel like it's so stupid. I just feel like that conflict between
me Ethan especially over something as stupid as like
are we
like there must be something better to fight on. I'm not saying
nobody guys there's just come on let's move the conversation
off of the thing and the credible allegations that I was hoarding.
Okay. I think guys, I just love the conversation to go anywhere
else. Ethan, we don't we don't hold child. Right, Ethan? We're
not child. We We don't like this stuff. Right, Ethan? Right,
Ethan?
Say I'm right, Ethan.
Or I'll I'll tell everybody else what else your dad was off to.
Say I'm right. What you can criticize me if you didn't think
I give a dumb take on something or do something stupid or whatever.
I think that's totally fine. I have called out Ethan for doing
stupid things. I think he I think ironically I guess right now
unironically I guess most of his like call outs when he's trying
to get people like Fresh and Fit or um
or even the Noah Samson thing I think the ProJared thing he tends
to miss the mark on that sometimes and I'll call him out when
he does dumb stuff like that. Okay. But the just the ultra unhinged
like this person is a murderer predator. Like there's just I
just don't unless you want to go like full snark coded. I just
don't see the Yeah, I just don't see the purpose for that. full
on snark coded. I don't know. The snark word is just so stupid.
When you hate me, it's snark and it's evil. When I hate you,
that's based and defensive. Okay, I'm just being defensive, guys.
Like, you're just saying people who dislike you, you're just
calling them all snarkers and and like categorically dismissing
anything they say. It's just so lazy. It's so
It's It's essentially okay what lefties used to do when they
call somebody racist, right? When they call Dest,
you're just a bigot. And now I don't have to listen to you, bigot.
It's the exact same thing. I'm just going to use some word that
immediately dismisses anything you say. I'm not going to do any
analysis. I'm not going to take out I'm not going to take any
of your criticism, right? I'm going to pretend you don't exist
because you're a snarker and everything you do is snark, actually.
Okay. Yeah, I think that's all I got. What happens if he makes
three or more videos about you with the worst Oh, if he keeps
making content on me I keep making lots of content. If you want
to keep making content, we can do it. I mean, who's your audience
at this point? Like, who are you making the content
Like if we want to become snark, >> that audience has and
probably always will uh hated Destiny. Okay. They've always hated
Destiny. I don't know. Yeah, they he can make Destiny hate content.
That would be fine for Ethan. They're they're going to they can
make hate with Destiny hate content. Absolutely. The crew will
be into it. Uh Kiwi Farm streamers, we can do that. Like I said,
I don't mind. If you want, we can do it. I just Kiwi Farms Stark.
Kiwi Farm Stark. Either we could stop talking about each other
and you could stop pointing out that I accepted
from a minor, okay, over the internet and then I kept that on
my computer, told Willy Mack as such or on some device I maintain
control of. Either we can stop talking about that or we're both
going to be snarkers or Kiwi farmers or something like that.
Okay, the only option we have is for both of us to stop discussing
that minor I traded
with. Okay, that that minor that I accepted from, we need to
stop talking about that or we're going to be snarkers. We're
going to be Kiwi farmers. It's going to be gross, man. >> I
just feel like it's not I feel like it's not a productive use
of either of our times. But yeah, can you please give a recap
of how this even started? I feel like he got mad for playing
Hassan should die and then suddenly decided to nuke you. Is that
accurate? Um, a quick recap is basically
um the Hassan said some unhinged crazy like two weeks ago and
then I was typing in chat that basically like if if
the
I want to repeat everybody spam reports my [__] right
now. Okay. But like basically like if this is the standard that
we're saying people like you can justify basically any like person
if this if these are the standard. >> Hold on. I'm gonna
roll it back to the Hassan thing. Is he saying Hassan started
this with a military target? Um, a quick recap is basically
um the Hassan said some unhinged crazy like two weeks ago and
then I was typing in chat that basically. Okay. What happened
first? Was Rose proven to be a minor first or was Hassan I think
it had to be uh Ela is a valid military target first. It was
it was it was it was it was right. It was that first. But like
the real impetus for this fight was Destiny. No no no no no.
It had to be the minor first. Right. Because because Ethan's
response was, "Yeah, yeah, yeah, it had to be the minor first,
right?" It was Hassan first, then like 4 days later. Yeah. Okay.
When did Destiny say the thing? He said it right away, right?
But I think it was Philip DeFranco did it like a day or two later
and then H3 did it a day or two after that, right? Where they
went over, they watched the Philip DeFranco thing and Ela's like,
"Why the [__] is Destiny even talking about this?"
Yeah, I think that's how that [__] happened. Okay,
but regardless, the only way this fight happens, the only way
Ethan like even goes after D like basically references Destiny
at all, I think in a negative way is if Destiny gives Kiwi Farms
the means to dox the minor, he
that's that's absolutely critical. >> Like if if
the
I don't want to repeat everybody spam reports my [__]
right now, okay? But like basically like if this is the standard
that we're saying people like you can justify basically any like
person if this if these are the standards these are the rules
are going to apply like you can argue like you could people for
tons of stuff it's not good for and then Hassan specifically
in this context
and then I think that Hassan who is petrified of literally any
criticism whatsoever relating to his conduct or his political
positions. He sees my message and he tries to make me an out
where he just cries about how mean I am. Personally, I don't
think almost anybody bit on that. Hassan kept trying to force
it and cry about it. But then for some reason, Etha and Ela jumped
on and they were like, "Oh no, like we almost had Hassan and
now he has an out." It's like, first of all, you don't almost
have Hassan. Hassan has been saying unhinged crazy for 2 years.
None of this is going to be the thing that uh you didn't have
Hassan because in this particular case, Hassan was not calling
for Eli to be a valid military target. wasn't calling for Ela
to get. He wasn't even being that unhinged or crazy. Okay? Like,
this is one of the cases where we've just totally made up what
Hassan was doing here. And people could say, "Oh, well, the environment,
the environment, the environment, guys, we're in a really charged
political shut the up." Takes him down. And then two, why would
the why would anything I say even matter? The only reason why
it could matter for you guys if you make it matter. Just don't.
Even if you disagree with what I said, don't just say that. You
know, Destiny said, "I don't know. We don't agree with that necessarily,
but who cares? This has nothing to do with what you said. We
don't communicate. Listen, the thing that frustrates me the most
on this is that >> Don't disavow me. Why would you disavow
me? You don't have to disavow me. Hassan won't even disavow bad
and you guys have to disavow me. What the [__] man?
People are um
people are uh making all these assumptions that I'm like puppet
mastering Ethan or that I control Ethan or that we have these
conversations behind closed doors. And then I feel like Ethan
acts like we have these conversations behind closed doors with
the way that he acts because um
Oh [__] Yeah, because when he tries to do these things
saying like, "No, I swear I'm not controlled by Dusty. No, I
swear he's not puppet mastering me." It's like, "Oh, that message
that was a really bad time to send that message." Sorry. I was
doing it. Sorry. Um the um Yeah. No, when he when he is so like
uh when he's so excited to no look, I can prove Des. He's like,
"Well, bro, you're literally making it seem like I'm controlling
you by showing how desperate you are to show I'm not controlling
you." This is like the like dollar store manipulation attempt.
Ethan, when you talk about this that I was m that I was hoarding,
okay, when you talk about this that I had, Willie Max called
the cops. When you talk about any of this, it's like it kind
of just shows that
maybe I did control you. Maybe you're like feeding into that
narrative that I did cuz you're trying so hard to get away from
me that like can't Why wouldn't you just embrace me? Then it
doesn't look like we work together at all. I are we Dude, he's
not even remotely like thinking about the things he's saying,
is he? You really think about it? Something totally insane. If
you really think about it, when you say that I'm like a child,
that I collect child
and won't delete it despite and I lie about telling my lawyers
that I have it. When you say all those things, it really just
kind of shows that maybe I do puppet master you after all. Like,
if Ethan and I were actually in communication behind the scenes,
then I would understand a little bit more. It's like, "Okay,
bro. I understand you got to throw me under the bus for this
one so that people don't think we're gonna together. Fine, let's
[__] go, bro. But it's like we don't talk at all.
I'm gonna be honest.
I Where's
incredible incredible stuff? >> That was like a little
revealing. >> What's that? >> Who does he not super
attack that has like semi thrown him under the bus
>> Uh,
that could be revealing. Yeah, that's sort of him revealing his
thought process. Hey, why don't you guys like throw me under
the bus here? And uh I get it. I get it. Just so people don't
think we're working together. I think I might have already said
this on stream. I feel embarrassed because I have tried to message
Ethan I think two or three times in the past. But it was to his
Twitter account and I somebody said something in chat about him
not using Twitter like, "Oh yeah." And then I realized I looked
at those messages. This is like over a year ago. I'm like, "Oh,
I'm literally just these DMs off into the void." Okay. Like a
loser. So no. Yeah. I I don't know. It's dumb. I think there's
better people to go after. I think there's better issues to focus
on. I think there's better people to attack. I think there's
better stuff to talk about. Um, you know, if comes out in the
future after my court case is over or after, you know, the Willie
Mac shows up with with all his federal buddies, you know, hey,
cover it then and talk about it then. But until then, yeah, I
just especially the whole like digging digging through like past
clips and stuff is just I think super wacky.
>> dude, it's crazy to drop your response to go super hard
on Twitter at this guy, to bring up like a whole bunch of about
him and then to go, I think it would just be silly to continue
this. Isn't that crazy to just like hit this guy a whole bunch
and then be like, ceasefire?
Like, imagine
does October 7th and then just go, "Bro, ceasefire? Ceasefire?
Hey, cease ceasefire."
Could it be possible that Ethan got lured into this by his team
or other people? I do think unfortunately there's a lot of pressure
on Ethan by his crew because his crew
Oh, this is the other thing he'll do. He loves to guess at these
dynamics and say like give people little outs like
I I kind of get it from Ethan's perspective, right? Like Ethan
he they're all like Hassan dick suckers on that crew and they're
all going to like pressure him to go after me cuz they hate me.
And I get it. That's a lot. That's a lot to deal with for Ethan.
And like Willie Mack, you know, I don't even hate Willie Mack.
I get that Willie Mack did what his conscious said. And I get
that like he talked to Nicholas Dioro and Nicholas Dioro would
have told him that he has to report it and he has to make a video
outing me because Nicholas Dioro hates me. Totally mind controlled
by Quean and the the Queenman and Jto Hassan Cabal. Nicholas
Yorio told Willie he had to attack me. But if Willie if Willie
I understand Willie doesn't have agency. I understand Willie,
you know, I'll forgive Willie if he can just admit that Nicholas
convinced him to do it, right? Like it's it's so transparent
that he's trying to give these people like an out. And I don't
think he realizes just how repellent the uh this stuff is to
people, right? This used to work for him. These kinds of little
like olive branches, they used to work, but now he's like the
child guy. That's who he is. And he he has to he has to engage
with any of that evidence to sherk that label. Until he engages
with any of the evidence at all, he's the child guy based on
what I've seen. >> See Samson, I suppose. >> I don't
watch H3 a lot. And I don't mean that as a burn. I don't watch
any content. Anybody that has watched my channel for any period
of time knows I don't watch any content. I just don't have time
or the >> Hold on, hold on, hold on. Oh, okay. >> The
inclination to I just don't. But it seems like most of his crew
are like Hassan Simps. I know that that AB star killer guy I
think is right. He's the same guy. And there's a few others um
who are super they were whatever. I don't know if they're just
lefty propellies in general or if they're big Hassan simp. So
like whenever Ethan's talking about Assan they just like nervously
sit there not saying anything but then when they're talking about
me they're giddy with joy. Um yeah maybe that's it. I don't care.
I actually don't care. I don't give a [__] what the
reason is. I don't care what the reason is. I don't care what
the rationalization is. But yeah. >> Oh yeah. Let's gamer.
It only counts like where you chat. Like you have to be chatting
for the timer to count. It it it can only see chat messages.
So yeah. I know. I know. I know. Any chance talking with Ethan
live or you just don't care? I have no idea. I don't think Ethan
wants to meet me ever live cuz it's like a moment of like
I I think Ethan is genuinely really petrified of not being able
to shake the Destiny puppet allegations. Like if he wants to,
sure, but I don't I don't even know what we would talk about
at this point.
>> Dude, invite Destiny on and just walk him through the
whole thing he skipped. Walk him through that whole thing and
just explain to him, "Don't worry. Uh, this is not affecting
your court case. Like, how you met this person, how how this
person was found has nothing to do with your court case. Don't
worry, I got a lawyer to check this." Actually, we got a lawyer
to check it. Actually has nothing to do with your court case
possibly affect it. All right, dude. Oh, Andrew couldn't do it.
Could you imagine Ethan like if if there was a world where ethics
didn't exist or something? Okay. If Ethan could just pay Andrew
Breler to like consult with him and just be like, "I just want
to ask him about this stuff and get the okay." Obviously, Brett
would never do that, but I'm just saying that should be what
they talk about. And it should all be on Destiny doxed this girl
who was a minor when he her because for what reason? I have no
idea. He was taunting Kiwi Farms. He was taunting the Kiwi Farms
thread. He decided to get her doxed, gave her face, her full
face and college, right? It's it's so baffling that all relevant
could not believe that Destiny would just do that without knowing
she was 18. And Destiny's given no solid proof. By the way, when
you asked Estie what his proof was that she was 18, it's well,
she was like selling nudes on Twitter and she told me
like that's that's the proof he had. Well, she told Listen, man,
if if she was under 18, then like she was selling child.
And wouldn't that be insane?
Uh, no.
People do that. Did you see uh Ryan Beard mad at Ethan for getting
what he said in his video wrong? I did see it. Somebody asked
me if this was real yesterday. Who the [__] asked
me that? Who asked me that? Oh, I hold on. Let me see. I'll pull
up the I don't know what YouTube chat this was in this in some
YouTube chat. Okay.
But Ryan Beard threw this up in a YouTube chat yesterday. It's
frustrating having Ethan misinterpret some of my clips. I never
argued that Desty was saying it's okay to sleep with 14year-olds.
Yeah, nobody argued that. I told you Ethan totally failed to
encompass the Ryan Beard video. Uh it it sucked. It it his his
really sucked in terms of he was going to use the Ryan Beard
video, but he just took the clips and like
totally totally it up. It can't be Queen's chat. This would be
the eye, right?
I think. Wouldn't this be the eye in Queens chat? Although in
H3 chat, it would be an H3 logo, too. So, maybe it is.
Okay. All right. Let's continue on with this. Let's continue
on. But I mean
was I would always go on H3H3 obviously whether talking about
Israel Palestine or current events or whatever other
um yeah like I would always do that but not but but to debate
um to debate like past clips and no that is stupid. Don't debate
don't debate past clips. Just debate specifically the the finding
out that your former partner was 17. You just clear that one
up. Just clear that one up for us, man. I think it's stupid.
I think it's dumb. But anyway, I'm um Yeah, like I'm only saying
this things
I've heard that. Okay, I may be I may be a bit aware of of that
being a thing. >> I'm only responding to Ethan. I only
ever respond. I'm only responding. I'm only responding. I'm only
responding. Okay. Um he complains about his hack email info while
laughing about your hack messages gleely. Yeah, like you can't
realistically put out an Instagram story complaining that
I won't say the name on stream, but complain that your old Reddit
account got found and complain that it was through hack info
while you're literally gleefully reading through like leaked
revenge
of mine to your entire audience. That is unhinged. It is leaked
reven leaked
So, I just don't understand how he can make this claim over and
over again. You remember yesterday we had this on the bingo.
He has literally re leaked revenge of multiple other people and
then read them himself on stream.
I just don't understand how he could possibly make himself the
victim in terms of somebody reading his on a stream. It's it's
nuts.
Crazy disgusting. It is crazy unhinged. You've like seated any
moral high ground there. Um yeah, but that's all they got. I
told you I um
I banned all my No, I didn't ban, but I told people to curb the
H3 posting and all that so we're not just doing this for days
and days and days. And yeah,
Rose has done 600 reviews reading. Yes, he's also done all of
the reviews. Yes. Leaked leaked leaked text. This guy has never
cared about other people's [__] getting leaked and
and not like covering it, right? I just I've never seen that
before. this whole idea that it's like when it's Destiny, well,
his his like are actually revenge porn, but he actually engages
in leaking that exact info about other people and feels nothing
nothing wrong is is there's nothing wrong that he's done there.
It It makes no sense to me at all. >> Okay, wait, hold
on one sec.
>> Gross mouth noises.
I I won't do that to you guys anymore. Okay, it's over. >> That's
bro, you need to be way less chill. Uh, you let people get away
with way too much. Um,
IMO seems hypocritical for H3H3 to complain about old comments
getting leaked. Did he complain about it? I didn't see him complaining
about it. I saw him saying it was him and saying that it was
like an old satire account. I don't I feel like that would be
really crazy to complain about it if that's what he's doing.
Maybe. I mean, like I said, I don't I don't have I don't think
I've made any new streamer friends over the past year or two.
I don't I don't make new friends or streamers YouTubers. I think
everybody here is horrible.
Is the whole purpose of your Twitter Twitter post about the account
so that Assan and friends would go after Ethan with it so you
can go back to streaming while they fight? No. Well, the point
was he was still continuing to tweet and call me a So, if we're
going to continue to roll around in the mud, I love rolling around
in the mud. That's what I've done for the past like from 2010
to
No, it's been like all of 2024 and 2025, too. I don't know. I
don't know why he's pretending this isn't the case.
I when has he gotten out of the mud? He keeps he keeps doing
this thing where he's like gaslighting people into believing
he got out of the mud at some point. It's never happened. And
when he was out of the mud, that's like the lowest his audience
gets is when he's out of the mud.
I don't I don't understand. This lie is just crazy.
>> Well, you can do that, but I I would obviously not want
to. 2044 was mostly boring IP stuff. No, it wasn't. He didn't
even start Israel Palestine until like uh what? Until Oh, wait,
wait, wait. I'm thinking of 2023. 2024 was mostly boring Israel
Palestine stuff. He engaged in a bunch of drama stuff on my stream.
He was still engaging in like my Discord in a bunch of drama
all the time. He just wasn't doing it on his stream as much,
but he was absolutely still doing it. I don't know why we would
pretend otherwise. Because I Cuz I don't cuz I don't Yeah, I
don't care about this as much. Do you want to harsh the Willie
Mac?
Harsh the Willie Mac. He's going to change the conversion to
those messages.
Flame 11. What the What the is this
>> This will be This will be where the stuff harsh the
Willy Mack. He's going to change the conversion
to those's messages. RIP. I'm sorry.
Um Willie, I don't know. >> Stop. Stop. Stop. I understand
that it's tempting to make these jokes. Okay,
I understand that it's tempting to make these jokes. I I get
it. Okay, I get it.
It's just like so funny. It's so funny. And it sucks so badly
cuz like a couple of my favorite people I engage with from this
community are actually Indians.
And
I just feel I feel so bad for like the rep the bad rap that Indian
males get online. Okay. It's so up, but also the joke is so funny.
I can't help it. >> I don't know how public these videos
are or if they've spread it all, but like the only reason Willie
made that video is because um Nicholas told him to. >> So
I of course I hold
>> the thing is is like, okay, now what is Destiny referring
to here? Okay,
this sucks cuz this is where Nicholas says Destiny is just totally
lying about me. Okay. Yeah, I know. We're going to watch the
Nick response. Don't worry about it. But I do want to pull up
just the the thing that Destiny's referring to here, okay? Cuz
there is something that he's actually explicitly referring to.
So I want to pull that up just to show it real quick. Just to
show it real quick. This is uh the previous stream. Okay. >> Why
Willie Mack decides to run and make a video like two hours after
DMing me? Now I understand. I >> That's a Wait, he just
straight up lied again. People are now arguing that Willie Mac
Show waited too too long. That's even the funnier part now. So,
basically, what night did I talk to Willie? I think he made it
like the next day, but I don't have that right in front of me
that I could show you.
So, he reaches out to me and he tells me about this and he and
we're talking and Willy's chief concern. I'll say this cuz I
don't think he'll have a problem with it. We were trying to like
flesh out a little bit of like could leaking this to the public
damage a criminal investigation? And I think because his his
thing was like, well, if she's >> absolutely could and
and >> got involved, what are they gonna do? And I go,
listen, if this guy's saying that he has alleged material on
his hard drive, and if the police choose to investigate that,
they don't really need the victim.
They just need to confiscate the hard drive, right? Like you
don't Yes. Did Nicholas think through what he's saying here at
all? >> Have to go get a victim's permission if somebody
gets reported for to like look through their drives. And um so
I didn't think that there would be any like the biggest risk
I guess would be him microwaving it or hitting it with a hammer
which was even funnier cuz it was happening while he was live.
So if he shut off the stream everyone would have just started
saying he was going to go blow up his hard drive. So what I said
to Willie is cuz his voice was I mean I got to be honest with
his voice was kind of shaky. The guy was nervous. He doesn't.
Dude, nobody wants to be in a position. Dude,
>> well, he's like having a breakdown because of how hard
he swept for test >> where somebody has come to them and
told them that they've a committed a crime, b done something
truly horrific that doesn't reach the level of crime, but like
has massive implications,
right? So, like Willie wasn't really feeling very good when he
called me. So I told him, you should just take a breather, come
back to this, look at this with like a fresh set of eyes tomorrow
or like the day after and then make your decision because ultimately
this is obviously going to come out, but how you want to do it,
you should be like you shouldn't be uh frantically thinking about
it like 2 in the morning. You you should give yourself a couple
of seconds here to like regroup and figure out how exactly you
want like did you do you think that he should have made the video
at like 2 in the morning or something after I talked? I I just
think that if Willie had his own independent thought process
that wasn't, you know, filtered through the lens of Nicholas
Dioro, and I'm not gonna say that Willie like only made the video
because of Nick or Nick like encouraging. I I don't know exactly
what happened here. Although Nick is saying he gave him like
a thumbs up to do it. Why the would you think I don't know if
this would compromise a police investigation? I'm going to ask
Nicholas Dioro. I got I know who you should ask and it's pretty
simple. How about the cops? How about you call the cops again?
Say, "Hey, detective. I forgot. Can I talk about this publicly?"
How the does your brain go, "Why need to talk to Nicholas Dioro
to see if I can talk about this?" How about you just ask the
cops if you could speak publicly on it? If that would compromise
an investigation. Now, common sense would tell you that yes,
it could easily compromise an investigation. Like, literally
saying you called the cops. that that getting the ability for
cops to confiscate property for somebody else is not a fast process.
It's not like immediate, right? So, obviously making the the
video like immediately or close to immediately would be a problem,
but I just don't know why the you wouldn't call the cops and
just say, "Hey, detective. Uh, I I totally forgot." Oh, you gave
me your card. Yeah. Let me call back you with your card number
here and just say, "Would it be okay for me to make a video just
saying that I reported this to you and putting that that segment
of the conversation in there?" This is like, "Yeah, dude. Uh,
what is it?" Liy's like um Liy's like Hannibal
You guys ever watch that scene from Hannibal? Willy's like Hannibal
at the end of that. Where is it? Where is it?
Where is it? Where? Okay, hold on. What's the guy's name? The
Minnesota Shrike.
Garrett Jacob Hobs. Yes. This is This is like Willie right now.
Okay.
Willie Willie like actually he reports he reports Destiny and
he's in the process of like helping the cops like figure this
out and he he calls up. Okay. He calls Destiny up via video.
>> Me and I suspect we'll never meet. This is a courtesy
call. Listen very carefully. Are you listening? >> They
know. >> You just wanted to see. You just wanted to see
what Destiny would do. Okay. You just wanted to see if he told
Destiny if he if he made it clear, hey, I reported you. What
is he going to do? What is he how's he going to react? I want
to see.
Now, of course, this is purely fiction. the actual canon events
of the Hannibal television series are more realistic and and
more based on real life than Willie having the presence of mind
or the intellect to pull off anything like this. Okay, obviously
I'm I'm I'm fantasizing but
in Jesus Christ. In any case, okay, in any case, let's continue
onwards. This is I I guess we'll continue on with this. I think
there's a Discord message as well that kind of leans in the same
direction. This is Nicholas talking about how he talked to Willie
when Willie was not sure if he should make a video or report
Destiny or >> Did you do Do you think that he should have
made the video at like 2:00 in the morning or something after
I talked to him when I got off stream? I don't think so. I think
it was better that he waited filmed it properly the next day
and then edited the video and put it out. That was that was my
perspective on it. But Destiny is saying that he like within
two hours went and posted this video >> You claim to care
about and you're hyping up a dude who has a segment on a show
called Ultimate Review. Willie Mac decides to run >> is
Mr. Oreo. Destiny was a good game, but the streamer was always
a scumbag. >> Well, Destiny and Destiny the game are kind
of very similar. >> Shout out to >> where like Destiny
had really good arcs, you know, like when Destiny was debating
Vos about like uh submitting to the mob. That was like the Taken
King, you know? But then,
okay, I think that's probably about it for this. I don't know
if he does more here. I had this Discord message. I've lost this
Discord message somehow. I I can't find the uh the actual Discord
message. Uh let's see
I'm just trying to find the the Nicholas Discord message of him
saying that he talked to Willie.
Somebody sent it to me. I could have sworn Porter Beller sent
it to me and I don't see it in our DMs anymore. I've lost it.
Am I crazy? There's a there's a Discord message from Nicholas
that is talking about this and I I literally can't find it.
>> Okay, hold on. We'll we'll go back to the Destiny thing.
I'll find it >> Willie just responsible though. Um, I didn't
notice. I was going back and I was just rereading through our
messages or whatever. Um, thinking like what else wanted to happen
and I realized that at the beginning of that conversation like
Willie is literally saying he literally says he even has in his
YouTube video although it's like half a second. It's like five
frames. Um, where he's like, "Oh, hey, like I'm just want more
information about this. This is all off the record. I'm not making
a video on this of course." And it's like, "Oh, so I'm like not
even I'm just like half me."
Okay, we got it. We got it. We got it. We got it. Destiny's talking
about how Willie apparently said this would be off the record.
Unfortunately for Destiny, I I don't know why he wouldn't understand
that. If you actually if you actually have and you're going to
make it clear to Willie, which you did, that you have that that
falls outside of like this is off the record. Okay. You couldn't
say that you were like about to decapitate somebody in your basement
and Willie go just goes, "Yeah, I said this is off the record,
so I'm not going to say anything, buddy." You cut that guy's
head off.
That's not how this works, man. You're saying I can't to admit
admit to murder off the record or like like literally that you're
about to go murder somebody or like that you're committing the
crime actively? Yes. It's crazy. Le's concern when he called
me was if it was going to mess up any police investigation going
forward. I advised him it most likely wouldn't, but take a breather
because he was clearly freaked out. Uh so I can understand that
they probably it sounded sounded to me that Nicholas was analyzing
this through the same lens as the pixie thing where like hey
if we do this without the victim involved like isn't that going
to be rough for the cops? But they didn't think about the lens
of like, hey, you're warning the guy who has this stored in some
medium that he needs to get rid of it. And he could technically
get rid of it there. Yes, he absolutely could. Nick said he talked
to a lawyer. I don't know who. Okay. Um,
here's the thing. All right. that always concerns me about like
Destiny and this stuff is
Dan has actually been on my stream talking about how he understands
everything about data preservation, how to get rid of stuff and
how to make sure stuff's gone permanently, right? That is a passion
of Dan's, right? To know how to actually get rid of stuff so
it cannot be found.
I guarantee you Dan knows exactly how to deal with a hard drive
to make sure like whatever magnets you need. I guarantee you
he knows the exact kinds of magnets, right, to get rid of everything.
I promise you, okay? And that as far as cleaning up the digital
footprint and I I think he knows all of that stuff, okay, thermite,
whatever the case would be.
Now, I don't think Dan I don't think Dan knows that because he's
like uh because he's like a predator or something. I think Dan
knows that because he has like a like a passion for this like
area of knowledge. Okay. So, I think it's a little different.
It's a little different.
But that would be the concern is they they could just get rid
of the evidence, right? And yeah, it looks bad for Destiny lying.
But here's the thing. Destiny's just lied, right? Like he's actually
gone on the record and said, I believe with regards to his criminal
case, sorry, his civil case, that when he admits fault to straight
away in those DMs, that's not him saying he sent it non-consensually.
That's him saying that he's just feeling really bad that something
bad happened, right? Like he will just lie. He understands that
lying is like his best approach and eventually like the if the
if the outcomes come down to you get caught with child or you
get caught deleting data. I do believe he choose to delete data.
In any case, I it might not matter. It it it might not matter.
Okay. Anyway, we'll uh we'll get back to the desk some of this
conversation. Depends on where you're >> Yes, we showed
the wiggler prank. Hellbent, thank you. >> Like Jesus Christ.
Um, yeah, the idea that like I mean it's it's his career. It's
his [__] The fact that somebody could talk him into
making a video on off the record. >> Yeah. Hellbent, just
go back a little bit in the stream. Just scan through the the
thing. You can watch us cover it. >> I feel like it's kind
of crazy unhinged, but hey, you know, >> I'm going to I'm
going to back this up about 15 seconds, >> of course. And
it's like, oh, so I'm like not even I'm just like half meing
through some of this conversation. Depends on why you asked.
Like Jesus Christ. Um, half memeing. Depends on why you asked.
But yes, I do have that video. But yes, guys, I'm just memeing
through this conversation. You know how you meme and say that
you have child? You know how you know that meme where you meme
about you have child right now and you're not saying anything
jokingly? There's zero tone indicators for a joke,
right? You know those memes? Those awesome memes. Anyone know
memes like that, guys? Isn't that such a cool meme? Let me pull
the Willy Mack DMs again because it's just it's so obvious that
like he's just lying and he's doing the same thing he did with
the Stro rate DMs where he basically just lies about what they
mean. Okay,
so pull these DMs up.
There they are. I think this should be all of them here, right?
Where he goes and says, "So, if you're sending me this, I'm guessing
you still have that video." Uh, depends on why you're asking,
but yes,
I created a copy of all our messages and everything when that
court case started. By the way, this is not the only time he
confirms that he does have it, right? So, bro, there's been allegations
since at least my last vid that she was underage and you still
have potential of her. Does Nessie say, "No, no, no, no, no.
You're misunderstanding me. You're misunderstanding me." Uh,
does he meme and say, does he me and say the exact thing a guilty
person would say? Cuz he doesn't say, "Yeah, of course I kept
it. I love that." Does he lean into it like he's off to it or
something? No.
There's no memeing. He just says, "I have an obligation to preserve
relevant evidence."
That's what he said. Willie goes, "Do you still have that child?"
He's like, "Yeah, I do." And he's like, "Wait, you really still
have that child?" I have an obligation to preserve it. Bro, where
is the meme? Where is the meme? There's no memeing. You're like
being incredibly precise with your language here. So, I created
backups of all the important relevant conversations with her,
Solo, Pixie, Straighter, Aaron, etc. That's nuts, man. I don't
think I'm allowed to delete it. The video. The video that Willie
is. You still have potential her. I have an obligation to keep
it. That's nuts, man. I don't think I'm allowed to delete it.
Is it a meme to confirm in a roundabout way like seven different
times in a row that you have that child still? That where is
the meme? Like there's a reason he doesn't go through the video
of Ethan going over these DMs, right? So, does this mean the
court case? No, this doesn't mean that he's handed over these
copies. It doesn't mean that. Uh Tom seemed to indicate that,
right?
That would be really bad. That would be transferring this stuff
again, I believe. Right. Because he you have evidence in November
of 2024 that he had reason to believe she was a minor. So if
he's transferring that for the court case, I think he's basically
put on public record. What's going on here?
Which, trust me, that's Listen, we think Darius can commit to
a bit. If Desi is going to commit to fooling everybody into thinking
he's a or that he retains child and he's willing to go and and
publicly transfer that to the defense in his civil case, sorry,
the the uh plaintiff in a civil case, that's a crazy commitment
to the bit, bro. I would not have committed to to pretending
to be a so hard that you end up doing hard time for
distributing.
That's crazy.
It's just a bit, guys. It's all a meme. Yeah. the idea that like
I mean it's it's his career. It's his fact that somebody could
talk him into making a video on off the record information I
feel like is kind of crazy unhinged. But hey, you know what?
That's like there's probably a bunch of arguments you could make
against Willie Mack. That's not one of them. That's not even
close to one of them.
That's like the one probably noble thing about what Willie Mack
did here was to like I do think if he hadn't made the video right
away, if he'd made the video and saved it until, you know, either
stuff popped or until he got confirmation from the cops in some
way, I would be like, "Dude, that was just the right thing to
do,
right?" But Willie Mack making it public or sorry, making it
known to the cops that you said all these things to him, that's
not criticizable by anybody. shouldn't be criticizable by Destiny,
which he's he's gone back and forth on this. Like, I guess if
you want to report me, then go ahead. And now he's like, I can't
believe he made private conversations, off the record conversations
public. >> That's life. Who cares? >> Crazy. Kilo,
it's crazy. Ethan and Willie claim you didn't respond to the
one part. Can you please play that part again showing you responded?
It's all
>> my video.
>> No, it's not. No, it's not. You just skipped it entirely,
bro. Dude, does nobody hold this guy accountable for anything?
There's no chat on screen right now. >> Wait, Willie lied
with this conversation. You said it was off the record. Yeah,
I didn't notice until I went back and I actually a friend pointed
it out to me and I was like, "Oh, nice." Oh, I listen, I've said
as much as I can, Ethan's the [__] lawsuit guy. Um,
like I said before, you can go read my court filings. Almost
every single thing I talk about on stream ends up thrown in some
[__] court filing. The ability for me to maneuver
in an environment where people are spamming the FBI,
he's going to basically say, "Okay, oh, hold on. Spamming the
FBI on me. Bro,
there's no way. He just spent so much time talking about this.
He's the one who got rosed doxed. He He's He's talked about this
so much. And now that like he's basically caught dead to rights,
guys. I can't talk about this at all. I I couldn't possibly talk.
Like I said before, you can go read my court filings. Almost
every single thing I talk about on stream ends up thrown in some
court filing. The ability for me to maneuver in an environment
where people are spamming the FBI on me. Okay. And then where
I have a civil liant again. >> Dude, I I make this complaint
all the time. Cool down on the FBI way too low. People just spam
the FBI on me. Okay. I got people showing up every hour. There's
just there needs to be like a a a 24-hour maybe 72-hour cool
down on spamming the FBI. Okay. It's up against me who is the
most latigious insane person of the world. Um the idea that I'm
supposed to just divulge more and more and more and more and
more information to not even deal with it's not like there's
even like if there was some victim that had come forward and
was saying like oh this person abusing me it's like okay [__]
my idea to make but it's not even why does there need to be a
victim the victim this is Destiny not engaging again with any
of the evidence at all right he will not admit that it is just
proven factually that this person was 17 when he was accepting
from her because if he if he even remotely acknowledges that
he is immediately guily guilty. He's immediately guilty. Right?
So, he is he is engaging in fantasy right now. He is in a fantasy
state that is not real. All right? He is operating as if Rose
was 18 when they DM'd. That is not the case. And he will not
accept any evidence. Uh there's a funny conversation. He was
talking to a massive massive sickophant in this chat who basically
was like, "Yeah, uh Tom Fullery proved this actually that she
is like under 18." And Destiny was like, "Bro, there's no way.
Uh, it's all like proprietary data and you can't you can't access
any of that. Actually, you can't access any of that. It's all
proprietary data. Some like in some niche database. It's like,
no, there's like there's like four different sources of this
information now. By the way, I'm just telling you there's like
four different sources of this information. It's been confirmed
so many different ways. It's not just a traffic ticket anymore.
Yeeb's calling it a ticket when it's a court document. A publicly
available court document that I believe anybody can register
to go look at. It's not like some private database.
It's a public document.
There are Facebook posts from the person she hit in in relation
to this this ticket. The person who she hit
the person actually posts when the when she hit them, she was
16 at the time. Do you see the very violent? That's what I'm
talking about right now, Jacob. That's not what I'm talking about.
It's pretty crazy. Okay, you don't even need to register. You
can just click login and it lets you. Dude, it's it's there's
just so many ways this has been entirely proven out that it's
it's very funny that he's just pretending this didn't happen.
Like, I don't know that I've ever seen Destiny just pretend something
isn't true when it obviously is,
right? Like just totally fabricating a different reality for
himself to hide in. Maybe it's happened before. Maybe I've just
missed it. But I I can't recall a time where he's totally fabricated
some reality to hide in because actual reality is scary. Yes,
this is true. Constantine man. Yes. That the date of birth on
that website is month month year year. It's obviously that way.
It's clearly that way with every other person who's on there.
There's like 95s for the years, right? There would never be a
95 for the date or the month. It's like 95 is the year. Yeah,
it's it's obvious she was a minor the whole time.
It's obvious that the screenshot that Desty sent to Willie is
on a date where she is a minor, right? It's August, I believe
17th, I believe. August 17th. I'd have to go look again at the
the DMs, but that is the the title of the screen recording that
Destiny says is a recording recorded by Solo of Rose, right?
He sent the VLC screenshot to Willie. Like it's Dude, he is he's
[__]
he's six ways towards the weekend. Is it six ways? Seven ways
towards the weekend. He's okay. It's crazy like the level of
cope we're operating at at this point. >> Even that, right?
It's just people digging through and like, "Oh, I think that
this happened and blah and this happened and we need it." It's
like you. No, that's stupid. If he doesn't like my answer for
that, Mr. Lawsuit guy. Um, I don't know. Like I said, he can
be my first interview after my lawsuit finishes if he wants to
chat. Um, I don't know. Like I said, he can be my first interview
after my lawsuit finishes if he wants to chat.
>> What was Hey everyone there. That was like Jordan Peterson.
I thought that was one of my donos.
Seven ways to Sunday. Okay. I knew there was some idiom there.
I just throw those out sometimes to see if I get them. I like
the one where Destiny was pointing at us before JTO decided he
couldn't handle it. What? I know what you're talking about. He
was trying to say the clip from his JF debate was out of context,
too. Yeah, I I pointed that out since signal that that was insane.
That like when you watch when you listen to the whole rant, he's
like, "This is all in the context of like uh of like a mental
as as a young person." It's like, "No, it's not. You literally
point out Wars or like somebody else who's on the call who's
19. You're literally talking about just people who are young.
That's your whole rant." And the funny thing was was I thought
he was going to cut it without that part of the rant. So, I was
like laughing at him for cutting that context out. But then he
just played the context and nobody in DG cared that the actual
context shows that he's clearly not referring to people who with
mental disabilities. He's saying anyone who finds if you're 30,
you find a 19-year-old attractive. They're basically the same
developmentally as a 15-year-old and you are a weirdo for having
that attraction. That is his point. It is not anything to do
with somebody who's mentally handicapped at >> Yeah. You
need to debunk all the random mouth lies. No, I don't think I
do. I one because a lot of them are not >> debunkable.
PayP.
Oh, we got a donate. >> Ruben donated $3. My comment with
a reply to a chatter. Please don't make me donate to call you
dummy. >> Okay. Uh I'm going to answer everything in chat.
Okay. Probably not. Anyway, guys, uh I just noticed that we're
2 and a half hours into the stream. We've not added time to the
stream yet. Uh guys, it is time for a shill. Okay. So, if you
like the content, I want you to go ahead and follow me on Twitter.
Join the Discord. Discord.gg/jstlk.
All right. Discord.gg/jstlk. GG/JSDLK.
All right, join the Discord. Be a part of the community. All
right, if you're in here, if you're in the chat right now, I
want you to download Discord, join the Discord community, follow
me on Twitter, okay? Like all the posts,
and if you really like the content, you go, you can go ahead
and extend it. All right? You can donate to the stream. You can
extend the stream. There's a couple different ways you can do
that. You can sub through kick. You can sub individually. You
can sub through gifting subs. All right? It's a 955 split. Love
subs on kick. You can sub through Twitch Prime through Twitch.
All right, you can donate through exclamation point donate the
links provided. All right, we've got kickbot. We've got streamlabs.
There's two different donation sites. You can buy a TTS message
through either one. Have it show up on the stream just like Reuben
Ruben has been. All right, I'll pin those links in the chat.
We are currently seven subs away from another hour on the stream,
guys. Seven subs away. Get the donations in. Add the time to
the stream. Okay, love you guys. Thank you very much for all
the support. I appreciate it. And let's get back to the content.
And two, because um I'm I think that Ethan said it really well.
The idea that people can just make random crazy unhinged accusations.
>> Kilo, thank you for the gift. That's appreciate it,
buddy. >> I think that Ethan said it really well. The idea
that people can just make random crazy unhinged accusations or
say random whatever things. Um and then you have to come out
and start divulging. >> It's not random. It's not Dude,
the random accusation is that I dox people, endorse doxing people,
or anything along those lines. am like a part of like a KF community
where we share Desi's revenge. These are random accusations that
have no basis in reality. A non-random accusation is that you
a 17-year-old and you retained material that you of a nature
that you received from her after learning that she was a minor
or might be a minor. That's not a random accusation. That is
based on facts.
He makes random accusations. These are not the accusations against
him are not random accusations. They're not fabricated. They're
not weird. They're not strange. They're not anything but just
accurate accountings of things that he's leaked or things that
he's put into the world. Okay? More and more information or accurate
accountings of things he's received from minorations >> or
say random whatever things. Um and then you have to come out
and start divulging more and more information in order to fight
it off. Nah, [__] that. >> Right. I didn't
>> That's cringe. That's cringe, bro. Oh, this was the
>> details to come out before I comment. This is not why
I went to the police. It's because he continued to write. I didn't
know. >> So, his um he zooms by it really fast, but this
uh I'm not going to make a vid on any of this because right now
there isn't proof that you knew or are suspicious, but if that
exists, that's really bad. Like you said, super red flag. Like,
yeah, the idea that this he's going to be publishing this conversation
and now I have to like line by line that I'm just like spitballing
to. This is [__] ridiculous. Not
>> But why is he saying he's not going to make a vid? Because
right now there isn't any proof that you knew or are suspicious.
But if that exists, that's really bad. If there's proof that
exists that you're suspicious or new, that's really bad. It turns
out Destiny was like, "Oh, let me test that. Let me give you
some proof that I'm suspicious." Hey, yeah, I retained a bunch
of child. Listen, if I wasn't, you know, current again, remember
this person's asking for $15 million, the um Pixie person, for
this lawsuit. I'm good on that one, okay? I'm not I'm not going
to be fighting. She's not asking for $15 million. That's never
been put in any court filing. He's asking for $15 million. He
just uses that to victimize himself. That is a lie to victimize
himself. That was a starting point for negotiations that Pixie's
team explicitly said is not really like a starting point. Make
us a reasonable offer. Right? Hey, we don't need that. That was
just like the initial point. That's not real. Okay. Make us a
real offer. He is just lying to victimize >> It's a court
of public opinion and in the court of uh the Southern District
of Florida at the same time. So, but yeah,
it is what it is. Oh, this is my manifesto that I wrote on this.
Can you watch a new Dave Smith Joe Rogan podcast?
No. >> Okay, I think that is it. I think that's it for
Oh, hold on. >> Oh, but wait, so Ethan's old Reddit account
was found right after beefing with Destiny. How crazy. He's had
beef with Snark for years, but immediately after beefing with
Destiny, his old Reddit account was found using the same method
that was used to hack mine. I don't know who. Guys, just so you
know, okay, I just want to point out real quick, just so we're
all aware, Destiny can't address these DMs at all because of
his court case. All right, he can't address the DMs, but he will
open up Willy's video, not watch it and address stuff, okay?
Not watch it and like actually deal with the fact that he said,
"Yes, I did retain all of this stuff. Yes, I did make copies."
Even when Willie multiple times says, "Hey, are you sure you
kept Dude, it's crazy that you kept child." He's like, "Well,
I can't delete it." Well, I can't delete it. He won't address
any of that because of the lawsuit, but he can go and grab Willie
saying that this is off the record from that same video. And
it's, trust me, no overlap with the lawsuit at all, guys. He
just cherrypicked. It's so funny the way he cherry picked >> [__]
Back up to H3. >> How great using the same method that
was used to hack mine. I don't know who hacked mine for sure,
but don't play stupid when I say I think it was someone from
the DDG community. This isn't me defending Snark, by the way.
hug as well. Smiley face. So the only reason why people knew
AB that you were posting on that subreddit because that was your
account, right? Which you admitted after people forced it out
of you, but then you said, "Well, it was because it was hacked."
Is because you are also friendly to snarkers. You said it over
and over again. You had them all over your stream chat. And you
literally said, I don't remember it was on an H3 show or what,
but you were like, "Oh, I think most of Snark is actually okay
except for like one unhinged person."
>> Guilt by association. >> You are actually a piece
of and also H3 community for doing this weird cringe they do
where they're like, "Oh, like you can't criticize the crew."
Whatever the [__] else that's this AB dude is like
a lot a lot of the crewing really hard on the show like put the
fries in the put the put the manifesto in the bag. Okay, you
are the ones doing the research on all hit pieces on me. You
are the ones that literally hung Ethan out there to dry on some
the most the slightest ever that you could dig up on Keform.
You guys can't even [__] watch the original videos
that you handed this dude to roast me. Also, you can sit there
and giggle that some pro genocide Israeli supporter pedophile
predator whatever the [__] that's what you think
I am to go down. So, no. [__] you guys. >> Wait,
did they I my understanding was Ethan sat down to do that and
said this is a passion project of mine. I did all the research
on this.
Am I I sped him up. Uh am I crazy on that? I could have sworn
that Ethan said this is a passion project of mine. I did all
the research on this.
Uh H3 podcast. Let's Let's take a look cuz I could have sworn
that's what he said.
Doubling down on Destiny. >> He said she went >> Let
Let me just see if that's in here. Maybe that's not in here.
Hold on. >> Brainwashing me. It's the craziest version
of 24 ever. I also want to clarify that the crew is catching
a lot of for apparently brainwashing me, uh, manipulating me
to talk about this. And this, I just want to clarify, is my passion
project. This I brought to them after I saw the Willie Mack video.
And I have always been passionate throughout my whole career
about these influencers who are taking advantage of their fans
>> So
it seems like Ethan did this on his own and is saying explicitly
the crew wasn't involved. But Destiny doesn't want to attack
Ethan. He wants the audience to like him. So he's going to try
to direct the crew. Destiny's It's so weird how he does this
this like uh this wedge driving, right? This is what he did to
the Lib and Learn podcast as well by trying to support Hutch
and say that these guys were all attacking him unfairly. He always
does this. It's like the most cringe obvious
like third grade manipulation that happens. Uh, actually Sally
said that your your shirt looks really dumb and uh and and yeah,
I don't know why she said that, but she told me that in private
and then he like watches them fight. I It's so It's bizarre.
It's just bizarre conduct from like a big >> Guys, these
guys deserve a lot of [__] criticism for that. Okay.
Like Yeah, that's all I'll say. You guys are really lucky to
have the jobs you have. You guys are really lucky you still have
the jobs you have. Um, you should